what it do this your boy soldier man
make sure y'all check me out on the
bootleg kev show
draco y'all know what's going on
all right yo boo lay cat podcast bootleg
kev show you've been hearing the song on
the radio we've been running it up man
the homie soldier boy
big draco is here ladies and gentlemen
yo what's popping y'all thanks for
having me bro yeah you move the mic in
front of you just so you got off the
show you know what i mean yes
man let's get it man welcome man hey you
know what's crazy is
the last time i talked to you was about
two years ago
just before you got locked up this is at
the height of the gucci soldier or the
gucci headband
which was the most iconic fashion
product in the last probably five years
i can't see anybody wearing that because
you'll see people wearing it now still
try but it's like i can't i don't see
that headband and not
associated with you like you they got to
retire it now
but you've always been a trendsetter
you're always starting stuff off always
since day one since i came in the game
of course
what i'm saying where's the headband now
is it just somewhere oh you have it i
got it you got it framed up
with glasses i wanted i wanted to like
all jokes aside it's gonna go into it
i'm sitting like in my little
whenever they do like a hip-hop museum
it's gotta be in there
so it's gotta be in there man um
congrats on the record though man cause
i was saying
your last run where you were going super
viral you were doing these interviews
and it was
it was you was the every single blog was
posted new
but and you were putting out music but
there wasn't anything that really caught
on now you got a real
record let's make it clap record um did
you know that this was like
gonna be the one or did tick-tock let
you know that like how did it like you
know what i'm saying
oh i knew it was gonna be the one yeah
so you knew you're like oh this is this
is it
yeah and then tastes like just like
reaffirmed your beliefs
damn that's crazy man how's it feel
though to have um because a lot of
people counted you out man
i feel good you know what i'm saying
like i'm just humble like you're working
just staying focused you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna get like dropping a lot
of more hits for y'all a lot of more
dances
and just like you guys stay down until
you come up you know what i'm saying
y'all straight until you come up so like
i feel like i just stayed down
and then like now i'm up but why are you
humble you you've done so much you don't
got to be humble
and by the way you being humble is a new
thing yeah we don't know you for being
humble
right i just feel like like that's when
i met with it now
i feel like like i was i did enough
talking i did enough all of that now i
can just like work
and just be like be successful do you
think you get all the credit you deserve
or do you think you deserve more like
you for all that you've done um
i'm not sure like i feel like at this
point it's kind of like
a debate like i feel like it's kind of
like it's it's a conversation
right you know what i'm saying so like
that's that's a start right i mean but
like
i ain't really tripping off it no more
it's as hard as i was seems like you had
a real big chip on your shoulder
i did you used to you know i feel like i
got i got my point across now
and the people like just from the
audience and i look at their comments
and like what people are saying
i feel like okay at least somebody knows
well let me tell you this
we interview a lot of people um and you
are the name
that always comes up if it's anybody
25 and younger they'll always give you
your props
it's like who influenced you every time
it's either you're in the conversation
or
chief keef's in the conversation you
know what i'm saying so i think that
your peers
at least the young your younger your
younger you know guys who are coming up
the generation under you
definitely recognizes everything you
brought to the game man salute to them
too man everybody that
you know saying gave me my pros all the
young artists all the artists in general
that came through
and name dropped me man shout out to
y'all i appreciate you all for the
support man keep doing your thing
100 now listen i'm a big wrestling fan
he's a big wrestling fan
i was really excited because i've
legitimately thought you were gonna
fight randy orton at wrestlemania yeah
i thought that's where all this was
heading right i wanted it bad
i was like bro this is gonna be epic
they're gonna have soulja boy
you you're definitely gonna get you know
you're definitely gonna get hit
hit with the uh with his move what's the
rko out of nowhere you know what i mean
but uh what what what what happened with
the randy orton [ __ ] was that fake or
was that like for real for real
i mean [ __ ] draco like i don't do
nothing fake like everything you see
come out my [ __ ] like real
right right so like like if you talking
about on my end or like yeah it was real
right right did you uh have any
conversations with the wwe about
being a part of like the show at all
like making an appearance because they
had to have reached out if not they
missed the bad
reach out they didn't reach out what
about um
you know jake paul doing this thing
right now a few years ago y'all supposed
to fight way before you fight anybody
yeah would you revisit that situation
uh knowing you see him knocked out nate
robinson knocked out dude uh ben alaska
whatever his name is
would you get in the ring with jake paul
today today i mean like i still want to
fight i'll fight anybody i fight whoever
like i don't care but like right now i'm
focused on my music right right
i had a lot of fight offers and [ __ ]
like that you know you were supposed to
what you're supposed to fight chris
brown and got cancelled he canceled yeah
he backed out of it right
yeah but yeah but the jake paul thing is
like we we
i'm gonna be honest with you we need a
black man to knock him out because nate
robertson made us look bad so we need a
black king to get in the ring with him
are you that are you the answer to that
yeah for sure i'm not the [ __ ]
how much money do i need to put on that
one just tell me right now right like a
hundred k
i ain't gonna put it that much i got two
james you know
how much like jake paul's gonna be
favored to win so if you bet on him
you're gonna get
way better payout cuz you know he's a
bad boy loki
now he he nah i mean i don't know like
right because
i don't know like i ain't him like have
you fought him nah you bought him
so it's like we just going off what we
see and it's like you gotta you can't
believe what
half the [ __ ] you see but you always
y'all was first he was training
everything for that fight when it was
going down huh who
was jake paul like four years ago five
years ago
oh yeah i was training yeah i mean it
was cool like we was ready we were gonna
do it but you know i had i got
it i got locked up and [ __ ] right right
it's all good like i ain't tripping like
i'm really focused on my music though
like i'm really focused on she making
clap the music video on my record label
i feel like that type of [ __ ] was just
like entertainment
also by the way another trendy set
fighting jake paul
he was supposed to be the guy to fight
jake paul and now look what's going on i
think you're the reason jake paul pipe
popping in
the uh boxing scene right now i put jake
paul on in the fight
but we ain't gonna say that what we
gonna say is [ __ ] jake paul he was
fighting what's the [ __ ] kfc
kfi what's [ __ ] knight ksi ksi i was
cool kf5 to be here
he would fight him before the whole
soldier thing so he's been doing this
boxing thing so we're going to give him
no that was his brother
his brother fought him oh wow he's about
his little brother
but more of the story we all look the
same white people i mean
nah they're just two brothers and i tied
one of them [ __ ] up in the music video
logan paul a long time ago
oh you tied him up in the video oh
that's cool yeah yeah yeah
with my wrist i put all them [ __ ] on
look lord stop more so short
the difference is that i've been
starting to fight and [ __ ]
back then when back then all the way
back then when he was just youtube
blogging and of course
i'm the one who started the celebrity
fight i'm aware i believe it
i really yeah man there was a few that
you were supposed to be a part of that i
was really looking forward to i was like
damn
um so now that you have this record man
i just asked you off camera
is there already a remix being talked
about or being um yeah
like who who do you want to get on the
remix or is the remix even done yet
have you gotten a verse back from
anybody
i already didn't want to like say no
yeah like i wanted to drop the video
tomorrow focus on this focus on all
right so the official focus on soldier
for right now the remix don't come
though for sure but like i don't want
the the talk be the remix the riemann
you know what i'm saying so the video
comes out tomorrow thank you tomorrow
uh 12 o'clock l.a time three o'clock i
saw some footage
of like behind the scenes lots of
females
lots of females this man ran off with my
light over oh hey
theo go get go get the lighter
um lighter
the [ __ ] lighter thief over here
you know laker fans is everywhere dubai
he's a lebron fan that's different i
respect
i respect a lebron fan now if he said
i'm a lakers fan my whole life but i'm
from new york i look at him crazy the
next
next is doing a lot right now though you
don't give a [ __ ] get out of here
oh no so the video looked crazy man uh
it had to be 20 females in there
uh yeah yeah we had a lot of females
assuming all of them have only fan's
accounts
i don't know well you know a lot of
rappers are doing the only fans thing i
feel like that's something
that's something that you would uh
thrive
yes you thinking about it i'm not only
fans you okay so your only fans
encounter you like
what are you doing on there i gotta
subscribe and find out
give us like a trailer what's the
trailer man because you know tigers
tigers on on [ __ ] only fans against
dick sucked and [ __ ] i mean he's
he's literally oh he's doing all that
tiger
is uploading personal porno videos on
his only fans
what what what what kind of content are
we getting on soulja boys are females is
it a game
what is it i gotta go go hit the
subscribe button
everything gonna pop up we ain't getting
nothing here gonna get the subscription
go find out
oh man is that how you like kind of uh
recruited some of the women for the make
it clap video
nah i just was like cool and like i just
really was on instagram like whoever
want to come to the shoot
hit me up type [ __ ] and start a little
group chat put all them in there
hmm hey man i'm happy for you you got
this record um
like we were talking uh when you when
you first got here i feel like
this record is kind of like a reminder
i'll go ahead and handle your phone
damn mom in the middle of the interview
mom's on the phone
i'm number one i'm number one on the
radio right now
number one i'm in the middle tell them
you tell them how proud listen
tell them how proud of you it is of me
said are we on the radio right now tell
them how to put it on speakerphone
you're speaker
[Applause]
her head she's trying to turn and listen
to it shout out to mom's how she feeling
now that you know uh you're you're home
and and things are going
in the right direction for you man she
lit you know i'm saying that's mom dudes
man shout out to mom dude she stayed
excited huh
she stayed there that's dope that your
mom's you've been in the game for two
like a long ass time mom still getting
excited
trying to turn radios on out i like that
come on
talk about uh is there obviously the
single's going crazy i'm assuming you're
working on an album
yeah i'm probably dropping my i'm just
um like i always drop a project
soulja boy.com part two nah probably
like
draco the album let me ask you this
because there's draco the ruler
and then you're draco and i talked to
him and he was
i don't think he was too fond that you
call yourself draco
but when you started calling yourself
draco did you know about draco the ruler
because draco's obviously what people
refer to as a gun
in general right so i feel like it was
more of a coincidence maybe you could
kind of you know
shed some light on that my name is
deandre cortez
wait everybody call me dre my middle
name cortez the second
first two letters of cortez the ceo is
draco
that's my name so that is why you
that makes sense deandre cortez draco
that's my name like what the [ __ ]
yeah i think that that was just
something that this is like i'm glad you
explained that
yeah that's my name yeah because he's
doing his thing you're doing your thing
it's like
it's not you know they can both things
can be true
100 man um recently
uh shout out to bow wow battle has been
getting a lot of his flowers finally
um i feel like you've been getting
flowers from a lot of people
but i feel like you know having him kind
of get get that big up from drake
was was kind of dope to see for him
because you know i feel like he's a
little underappreciated in the grand
scheme of things
um you and drake though
one of the more comical i mean yes
because he has legitimately stolen your
bars
this is factual there's i mean and i
don't think he did it like had like
a st like the way hove would pay homage
to biggie or whatever
you guys ever have a conversation like
at all since
since the i was i'd like to call it your
meme era
we'll call it the headband era of soulja
boy have you guys ever talk or anything
you guys have
how'd that conversation go cool
did you do you think people were more
entertained by some of the [ __ ] you were
saying about them a couple of years ago
or you think like i don't think anyone
really took offense to it anybody take
offense to it
what did i say the tiger [ __ ] the dre i
just think that all that [ __ ] we look at
i
look at that [ __ ] as a moment in time
like your inflection the way you were
saying people's names
is to this day if somebody shot you with
texas
if someone says yo you want to go eat
and they say like olive garden
olive gardens like what
mcdonald's that's culture
like you know what i'm saying it's the
train we set the trends but now nobody
took no i nev
i never got no nobody hit me up on like
no [ __ ] like i ain't hear nothing
but yeah do you regret any of like your
meme area any any of those moments any
of those viral groups yeah
what i'm gonna regret it for this [ __ ]
viral it was the truth and like i was
lying like i would
talk about anything all your videos any
moment that she's like damn i wish i
could handle that different
no that's what i'm talking about what
the [ __ ] everything i stand on it i said
it i meant it
it's dead like question the flat
interview
where you told the story about the
shootout another moment in time
right will you ever like i feel like we
need a short movie
where you're acting like i feel like
there that has to be put in a movie
because that story is so crazy
like have you have you thought about
trying to recreate that or like
i wouldn't want to create recreate that
because i i don't mean i don't mean like
like literally but like you know like if
you ever do a movie about your life
or some [ __ ] like definitely definitely
that's gonna that's good that's
that's a part of my life so when the
movie about my life comes it's going to
be in the movie because this was in my
life
man hey what was the first time would
make it clap you
opened up your tick tock and you you
were like
oh no this is it's over because i feel
like it happened kind of quick
um was it like one of these two i just
like the first yeah as soon as i did it
yeah the first day
first day you knew it yeah yeah
it was serious but everyone know joe
like because every like you gotta think
about it i've been releasing songs i
know the analytics
so as soon as i seen the numbers and i
like it was like
she did like a million the first day
crazy did you think
because did you come up with the actual
dance or did someone else come up with
it that was you
i came up with the dance and then the
tick tocks they through they remix on
and then [ __ ]
everybody just i didn't do so many
different variations of it though you
know what i'm saying but the main one
is just like straight straight viral are
you are you ready for fortnite to steal
your dance and put it in their game like
they do everyone else i'm not gonna
steal my dance but they're gonna put it
in there and put me in there
respectfully
because sometimes i mean they haven't
done that all the time they i think i
think no they stole a couple dances
there was a couple of them uh blackboard
jb [ __ ]
yeah sure yeah yeah yeah they're not
gonna play with me
yeah they can't man um hey what up man
how to interrupt the bootleg cab podcast
to tell you about our good friends
at odd socks all right yo shout out to
them for sponsoring the podcast but also
for being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loops socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
odd socksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cav and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddssoxoficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out thank me later
you're a big gamer
possibly the biggest gamer in hip hop
i'm a pro gamer sure i'd say so dmg
gamers esports
you've been doing that forever you've
been on the gta going crazy
i got my own server on gta like stupid
we got studio in
mcdonald's like [ __ ] you can't get in
the regular gta game i had a [ __ ]
mcdonald's in the gta games burger king
we store the whole lh of different
culinaries with lamborghinis
how long have you been working on that
world because i feel like you've been on
that
[ __ ] up in one day people capped me down
and was like bro i'm gonna make you a
servant we're gonna help you out pay us
and do this and
it was like two months every day they
would say we working on it we updating
it so one day i just was like
hold on let me see something and i
youtubed it and i read this and i read
that i had that [ __ ] up in 30 minutes
so you figured it out on your own man 30
minutes and now i had that [ __ ] flooded
the whole
pack like on twitch like 40 000 views
like
wow hey the uh the new thing on gta is
like the role playing
that's what it is so you're in there and
everyone put your world there's just a
bunch of role plays
soldier world gta rp role playing
because i saw the video of t grizzly
where he got kidnapped in the game
right right i guess his hobie set him up
in the game and [ __ ]
i was like what the [ __ ] i i've never
seen that version are you on
like you you play on twitch like uh
regularly
yes the twitch bag gotta be serious very
serious
yeah cause i was like talking to t-pain
and he does this like similar stuff and
t-pain is getting a
bag on twitch i got the most probably
how many subs you got on there they vary
they don't just stay at a certain
what's your biggest twitch month check
you've gotten
shh i don't think i would disclose that
bro it's got to be crazy yeah i don't
think i want to say well look i got like
homies to dj on twitch
i made a lot though like a lot of you
had to have at least you've had
it it's definitely in the six figures
yes
easily in the six figures yes easily yes
damn
yeah because i got if niko blitz made
three grand [ __ ] djing at it from his
apartment in north hollywood
just imagine that twitch [ __ ] is serious
you're very smart i feel like when it
comes to
your finances you have lots of streams
of income
you just announced the new gaming system
which is your second one correct
my second one i'm the first rapper to
release a video game concert
at soulja boy game instagram twitter and
tick tock
i'm about to put up 24 billboards all
throughout the city all over the world
and what's dope about this
uh console is it's got a bunch of
different types of systems on it right
fortnite
spotify apple music tick-tock netflix
wow it's serious it's not even it's a
home entertainment system handheld
though oh handheld
okay helio processor this
series touch screen how much you're
going for two hundred dollars
that's not bad twitch is like what or
not twitch
the switch is like three 299 that's not
bad yeah
get a five percent discount right now
soldier boy use that code
are you pre-loading your music on this
thing
it varies we're doing a lot of things
with this what you got to do is
every system a lot of customization
every system sold
you from the ground up yeah it's a
beautiful thing i own the whole company
is is is is i'm very
i'm very proud of this because it's like
music music i'ma say music was a
stepping stone to get into this you know
what i'm saying
and then like once you get into this
industry it's hard like it's not easy
it took me like three years to really
like get it how i wanted
how i wanted to be to get it at this
level that i'm at right now right you
know what i'm saying
but like yeah man it's different right
it's a whole different space it's
different from music it's different from
movies
it's different from anything i've been
involved in right now
are you trying to get in other fields
like no politics governments oh you love
video games no yes this is a passion
from the early i don't do
business based off of just like business
like you gotta love opening the
restaurant oh my god
no truck business you gotta be packed i
gotta be something i was you know i
wanna have a toy since i was young
i wanted to have my own clothing line
since i was young i wanted to have
my own video game console since i was
young so now that i'm older and i got
the connections
and i use music as a stepping stone to
get into these different fields
i can accomplish everything it seems
like too just based on reading about the
system is that it's a big improvement
from the first one
very big improvement because i think a
lot of people got might have got your
other
what happened with the other system
because it feels like i think some of
the shipping was slow
and then some people got it and they
weren't happy with it you feel like
that's just a learning process
we had to recall the first system first
system
it it garnered so much attention that it
got on nintendo's radar
and nintendo threatened legal action
because you had it you had everybody
[ __ ] on there right
well basically the games that were on
there were licensed and trademarked but
some of them wasn't but through the
company that i went through
they were supposed to be one hundred
percent covered they're supposed to
handle all that but there weren't they
wasn't
so once my name was on it you know i'm
saying it was you took all the heat yeah
yeah
but that's fine because we come back
bigger and better we go from
getting a cease and desist from nintendo
from them coming and now trying to buy
my company from me
damn you understand what i'm trying to
say that's crazy
and it's like oh yeah i'ma sell it of
course so nintendo's trying to buy your
company off of you they write billion
out of checks like this i didn't talk to
nintendo and google
from the two companies that i talked to
that's big
they trying to buy us out right now it
ain't even been a month too much like
this ain't even hit the shelf we just
hit amazon stores like three days ago
[ __ ] congratulations you think about
selling are you gonna i'm gonna
sell it you got to yeah it's just i got
like it's
i just got to like i would own it i
would keep it but it's like once you got
nintendo coming at you
it's just like do y'all thing right
i'm just so i'm just happy to just even
be and just hit it this is out so where
that's out youtube's 420. this is the
vintage song it came out 420
that's the crank that outfit i just
added the long hair i had the short hair
there
and you got the old school chat i
remember that chain got the baby nape
shoes on
okay the baby i just saw um that you you
you feel like you uh heavily well you
said you've been saying you influence in
a lot of [ __ ] which i agree with
uh you said that you influenced a lot of
people to wear vape i did but you
weren't the first
first don't matter whoever influenced me
oh i gotta give that to pharrell
and the clips when i met for when i met
pharrell this man gave me a pair of vape
shoes
i suppose i got a babe deal with my vape
collab bag i got vape song in the crank
that video
i got babes on in the toy right there
that you holdin
right now i got baseball right now how i
ain't how i ain't
stop playing my first album i said i got
me some baby names and it went platinum
that's fast actually i ain't no foreign
100 everybody i knew i messed with for
real i messed with whoever y'all talking
about but
as far as me i really live this
this wasn't no brand commercial on tv
that you saw when the post then said
we're gonna wear this because we know
this was in the hood in the trenches
where nobody knew what this was
and when i'm going to school when
bathing they're spending 600 700
on bathing days [ __ ] laughing at me
talking about
doing fake air force ones you're
spending 700
on the base bro everyone used to see 25
000 a show before i got signed i had
i was getting i was on the internet
making 25 000 a day i'll sound click
before soundcloud sound click was that
[ __ ] i was getting paid so i had money
to play with as legit
reselling selling beats on there yeah a
sound click yeah i really were cashing
out on base and renee was really
rejoining on me when i went to school
like uh because they didn't know
you need to get some georgias you need
to get some earphones one don't fake for
one and we really was beefing like man
we really stood on that baby nape [ __ ]
right and now to see everybody rock it
like it's cool it's the normal thing
it went like that when we wasn't coming
up right it wasn't cool to it
so yes i'm gonna say i made [ __ ] with
fair enough
i mean i think that you definitely
introduce it to the whole younger
generation the hood
to my people yeah trenches everybody
come from you know i'm saying shout out
to whoever whoever they said but come on
not like they didn't do it like soulja
wig
my crank that got over a billion views
well on youtube because i know they're
gonna career because they're gonna look
it up 580 million views on youtube but a
billion overall with everybody who copy
my [ __ ] together
i had bathing ape all throughout that
video whatever video whoever y'all
talking about ain't never reach half a
billion videos win whatever they whoa
okay so i reach more attention and reach
more eyes than y'all
they don't know y'all they don't know me
i don't care who own it
who promoted who gotta deal with it i'm
the one that put the trenches on it
the streets matter more than anything
hey what happened with yums
cause yums was a wave everybody was
rocking the yum [ __ ]
and then it feel like it just kind of
went away first rapper with the emoji
yeah i mean that was that was the logo
what's all your first
all the first you guys man we'll be in
here all day youtube
then your top 10 first that you give me
five you know you got the credit for man
on the first rapper on youtube okay on
the first rapper on twitch
on the first rapper to get signed
straight off the internet from high
school to a record deal
to jimmy iveen and interscope records
for over a million dollars
man stop playing with me what i'm the
first [ __ ] to
do all type of [ __ ] let them know on the
first [ __ ]
i'm the first [ __ ] to write and produce
a song
at 16 and go number one on the billboard
hot 100 for however many months it was
i forgot the other girl name who did it
it was a girl i don't even know nobody
never did that
these [ __ ] don't make their own beats
they got producers
i made the beat and i rapped on the song
and i recorded engineered it at my house
in the crib in the bedroom
facts and then flew out here with y'all
lit and met with jimmy i mean the
interscope with my feet kicked up
with a million dollars from high school
16. nobody never did that
that's nobody that's fair on the first
first
instagram badges where you can go live
on instagram and get paid and make money
from it
um aren't you tired of proving yourself
though like i ain't proving myself
i'm just he's just telling us yeah just
ask me what i did
you also i feel like where you i feel
like you do get a lot of credit as far
as
some of the things you just said but i
don't think you get enough credit when
it comes to
some of the artists who you kind of have
taken over your
under your shoulder like over your
shoulder before they were
quote unquote popping you know what i'm
saying i feel like i always see you
embracing
younger artists before the rest of the
world really knows who they are
um i know recently you talked about uh
famous dex
was sitting sleeping on your couch you
know what i'm saying he was supposed to
sign you originally
yes and then that obviously didn't have
didn't happen uh what happened there he
just
yeah he's just he chose another label
even though you gave him a place to stay
yes
damn i feel like um you
there's a bunch of artists like that
though you know what i'm saying that you
really kind of
you know you were kind of the first guy
to really [ __ ] with them that of
some notoriety like who are some of the
artists that you feel like you kind of
helped
help school a little bit when they first
were coming up you know what i'm saying
not say that you like put them on or
nothing but just some artists that you
feel like you really kind of helped
i'm done talking i feel like the proof
is in the pudding you know what i'm
saying do the history do the youtubes do
the
i'm done giving away clout i'm done
giving away free promo i'm done saying
rapper name
if i helped you cool if you made it cool
if you didn't make it cool
i don't have no i'm done like i don't
even kill no more you know what i'm
saying would you ever take a label job
like if a label wanted to hire soldier
boy to be
yes the vice president i supposed to be
the ceo of
one of the major labels right now i
supposed to be the president of one of
these labels right now
look how many artists i've discovered
for y'all that's what i was going to say
artists that y'all bumping for the last
half many years
been me so why shouldn't i have a
position at the labor i just found all
the talent that y'all
that y'all listening to you could be a r
for sure you run the whole a r to
possible
ceo ceo you got a ear
ain't no a r ain't no little nun i need
to hold i need everything they tripping
that's why i got my own label though
but see i wasn't the artist that was
putting these artists in contracts i
know what it's like to be in the
contract you were just helping him out
genuinely
nah he went down [ __ ] y'all supposed to
keep it real and still did the paperwork
but off the jump i'm not finna just put
you in no crazy country and then your
car something happened to your career
and you looking at me and then you're
right right right
so i'm thinking off the strength we
working off a handshake you we working
out loyalty and your word is all you got
in this world
so we working off your word i'm thinking
we finna ride it out till we
we're gonna ride it all the way out
right that's what happened with
with dex i'm assuming that's what
happened with everybody i hate tripping
right now you're just on the new wave
right now you're working
on your own trip no more free clown man
salute to them man much love much
respect whatever but you know
i got my new label 2021 i just saw my
new artist flow malcolm
from malcolm yes atlanta he got the
atlanta going crazy i got to bring him
out to the west coast so y'all could tap
in with him but
flo malcolm59 what happened to a wrap on
instagram
salute to a rare everyone living this
thing because i just think about i think
about the
og uh sodmg you know what i'm saying
and a rap yeah groups break up grooves
don't really make any hip hop
right it's rare for to see a group just
what's he doing in life do you even know
he's just chilling he's just living it's
just happening everybody don't have the
same passion i made
one around i tried to force him to sign
a deal i tried to put him on and
make him do it man this is a passion
that i had i really wanted to be a
rapper
i really wanted to do this [ __ ] i really
wanted to go platinum and get grammys
and live this [ __ ] and do this [ __ ]
he was just with me supporting me type
[ __ ] you know what i think it's dope
about you is i i don't know if a lot of
people know this story
um you had an artist you were working
with
m2k from vegas very funny guy
but the story that i heard was
you had left your chain somewhere in
vegas it was in a hotel room or at a
party or something
and dude got it and instead of anybody
would have got that chain
and been gone with it and hit a lick on
it you know what i'm saying
yeah he got in contact with you got your
jewelry back and that's why you signed
him
thanks and that's something that's like
and like look he's a funny guy right but
his music wasn't it
funny [ __ ] dude though i [ __ ] with
dude tough like his skits
he was kind of early on a lot of the
youtube pranks and [ __ ] right yeah but
when i heard that i was like yo that's
some real ass [ __ ] just like as a
gesture like yo i appreciate you for
keeping it a stack and give me my [ __ ]
back like
i feel like that's some [ __ ] that like a
lot of people don't have those kind of
principles anymore you know what i'm
saying
yeah man we keep it real you know what
i'm saying like that's some rude that's
a real [ __ ] so
you know i stand on it um
has there what has been the last thing
uh
because you know a lot of people for you
getting locked up getting out of jail
bouncing back do you think that you
going
going back in uh like like for the
extended amount of time do you think you
came out a better person like more
humbled uh
maybe a different perspective on how to
look at everything yeah definitely
i'm saying definitely changing my
perspective on life in general you know
what i'm saying my music career
just everything in life cause you got
nothing but time to think in there right
it's like not really because she it's so
much [ __ ] going on you know what i'm
saying but
at the same time you dig when i'm saying
hell nah ain't no time to think
yeah so you got out you you know because
i feel like we got a new i feel like we
got a new
like a new guy when you got out no it's
definitely not saying
it's definitely you know what i'm saying
definitely it definitely changed me
though you seem more focused
you seem very very like on just on your
[ __ ] like at the end of the day like
people want to want to fire from you you
know what i'm saying like and i feel
like sometimes the antics got a little
out of control to where people weren't
checking for your music as much as they
were checking for your antics
not for sure and i think i've said that
in interviews before because i've talked
to some of these young kids
who are known for that i'd be like hey
look like you know what i'm saying like
you want you you want the music to be
first now obviously you're different
because you're kind of a cultural icon
right you can get your twitch back you
could go act you could
you could do to do whatever you want but
like the root of all of it is the music
right you know what i'm saying so i feel
like ever since since you you've been
out you've been focused on that
yeah i've been locked in studio every
day like
every day every day every day every day
every day i can't wait y'all hear what i
got coming next like you know
so it's just like man musically man bro
i got some
some stuff coming and it's fun i love to
see the people dance i love to see the
reaction i love to see the streams like
i love it you know what i'm saying it's
always like i want people just think
like i'm just coming with
a hit and then i'm gonna dip off again
and like like this is the career just my
career like it's
she i'm just getting started i saw you
just reconnected with uh with keith
which i thought was dope because like i
said earlier i think uh when it comes to
our current generation of music
they'd be hard-pressed to find it's
probably you
and him and probably wayne as far as
like influencing the last
15 years of rappers or you know what i'm
saying
um how's your guys's relationship in
2021
do you you got you i feel like you guys
did like a [ __ ] best of both worlds
like
project in 2021 it'd be crazy for sure
i don't think anybody would turn down
the features like you guys could
probably call anybody and be like we're
doing a soldier boy chief keith out
oh yeah we got it we got to get on that
show um
when is your when is your album coming
though
might come sooner than why everything
i'm looking for the way this record is
moving it might come sooner for sure
but i really want to drop like one or
something i always do like a project
like around my birthday type [ __ ] no
matter what
right when's your birthday july okay
okay so that's coming up is there
anybody you're trying to work with right
now that you haven't worked with like
anybody he's like you always want to
work with you just ain't been able to
click up
nah and what about someone new that that
you're just a fan of
because like you have that ear like
who's someone who's not not anybody
who's off yeah
that's signing yeah i don't get every
freedom when they gotta pay me for this
no no someone who's already kind of on
i'm not asking you to tell me nobody
knew this on
if the people just popping like they are
coming and then the [ __ ] this out they
been out for years they ain't new
um ain't nobody knew this is just like
you know there's nobody who you're like
[ __ ] with there's some dope i mean
obviously
there's some brilliant artists no just
their music yeah like who whose music
are you listening
to that's kind of you know newer
free young boy um pooch iced tea
spoilery
[ __ ] soldier
do you ever feel like someone like young
boy has been through so much [ __ ]
uh since he's been on right do you ever
feel kind of like obligated being the
big homie to kind of reach out and like
you know maybe game up some of these
kids who might who might be making the
same mistake you've made in the past no
not your place that's fair
well look hey uh hopefully we're getting
this remix we get in the video tomorrow
tomorrow man stop playing she make it
clap man 12 o'clock la time 3 o'clock
new york time
there's a lot of ass in the video a lot
of that in the video youtube.com slash
old way
straight like that uh and then you got
your twitch you have
your only fans you have the video game
system which is souljaboy.com
trdrpocket.com traderpocket.com
at soulja boy game on instagram twitter
and tick tock
yeah man give me your address or
wherever i can send it the shipping
address i'm sending y'all like five
okay and then uh you said that there was
a code shout out the code
sold your boy is the discount code
trdrpocket.com you get five percent off
for sure go support this guy congrats on
the record
you make a [ __ ] tick tock video
hey we gonna do we go you down to try to
do this this damn so
does this we gonna try to do the
challenge we have some fun we gonna [ __ ]
it up
imma [ __ ] it up for sure anyway boom
soulja boy thank you for checking in
thank you for having me